dude that is it looks like what I think
it's a vagina today we are going to talk
about the female hoo-hah remember
laughing giggling a lot in health class
and pay attention much I could see that
from you I had her billion for myself
about vaginas because I went through the
process of you know having surgery to
have a vagina being transgender and
actually having you go into the process
I'd have to really inform yourself of
what it should look like how it should
work
I'm pretty like pretty high love when it
comes in vagina knowledge we went to the
gynecologist together and I was like
well if you want this you're gonna have
to know about it howdy let's see I think
it's four to six inches deep undated
maybe I won't have to save about seven
inches possible you look at me like I
know and I don't know that one room for
inches what do you think people just get
you just get like this much of your
penis in there I have a shallow vagina
what something what deep-set vaginas oh
that's like new girls I know about that
I think this is the service
no that is the cervix yeah I don't think
so thank you like this general area I
don't know much about vaginas either
it's within this circle that bumpy part
[Music]
well the pointer is off isn't big it
looks like he couldn't work that area
out it's like the muscles that push that
baby out some people are unfortunate
don't have that bit of muscles so they
have to have a c-section or something
that's a child with the big head yes are
you gonna help me work out my cervix I
guess so
I had never really dove into one or
anything but I know not like sexually
but like it's like looking into it let's
see some sort of bacterial growth inside
there that doesn't feel good I think
temperature or something to do with it
fairly ugly like what comes out and
that's not really bad and you can't
really have sex that you can hear you're
so good this is a bit better than I
thought
[Music]
I think your vaginal discharges when I
have no idea it must discharge something
would that be like when a girl is horny
and like she gets wet when she's about
how Sykes or something yeah vaginal
discharge they're a pretty good hardcore
band form I think it's not P right would
be P
it's like comes from a few different
reasons I think like this certain
diseases you might happen like a yeast
infection you can get from that if a
male decides to ejaculate inside of a
female the vagina can push it back out
possibly all the dynastar discharge
there's healthy discharge and it's
unhealthy discharge this is what to it
yeah plus a casa la pagina it's a whole
like biome inside you've got to keep is
this how my vagina it's so easy just
being a dude there is no one vagina you
know there's a whole bunch of variety of
Aegina that's such a beautiful thing to
have for the chart is like power like
woman power yeah
vaginas are like that's that's that's
what's up right there you got love
páginas no matter what
you
[Music]